we've talked a little bit about Ray
Kurzweil he is the director of
engineering and the world's leading
futurologists the director engineering
at Google I should say and he believes
that computers and robots will be much
smarter than us by 2029 by 2029
computers and robots will be able to
understand what we say learn from
experience and outsmart even the most
intelligent humans they'll be able to
crack jokes Wendy we're out of a gig
they'll be able to tell stories and
they'll be able to flirt and now we have
a quote from Ray himself and today I'm
pretty much at the median of what
artificial intelligence experts think
and the public is kind of with them
because the public has seen things like
Siri where you can talk to a computer
maybe they've seen the Google
self-driving cars my views are not
radical anymore I've actually stayed
consistent it's the rest of the world
that's changing its view now this guy is
the leading futurist in the world he
believes he's doing this thing right now
we did another story on it where he's
trying to live forever using the system
of vitamins and they're you know they
have these pills now that that can go
into your body and look around and
baptize vaporise diseases and
nanotechnology and nano bots and all
that stuff so this guy knows what he's
talking about 2029 our robots gonna take
over is that does that seem like a rough
estimate of a year that makes sense to
you I don't I don't know I just want the
robot to be able to load my dishwasher
for me not be a very happy person I
actually did get to speak with woz
once and he told me he was skeptical
about the singularity but he met with
Kurzweil and by the end of their
conversation he was totally convinced
that at some point computers and robots
will be able to take over or have the
same processes that humans do but will
they be able to change a diaper
you know like flirting one thing but
could they change my oil that makes you
order now wise you are talking about
Steve Wozniak I am former founder of
Microsoft created the computer yeah he
was
jobs like right-hand-man basically 20:29
does that seem like the right to figure
out how robots and computers aren't
smarter than us now are they may be that
you're liking my auto bill pay never
forgets to pay my back I'm I'm often the
person who forgets to do that and
everyone's always afraid in this moment
when you know robots are better than us
they'll start to kill us yeah like
robots can kill us now
like drunk norm there I kind of need
2029 to come around so that robots are
sophisticated enough to feel bad about
it ah so you want robot guilt that
probably won't kick in till around 20 34
yeah yeah I mean I definitely have a
belief that like the future is going to
be some combo with like AI robot and the
matrix and maybe a little Minority
Report and her yeah let me tell you
something about robots yeah her he falls
in love with it like you can have sex
with a robot now yeah you think you can
have sex with such as such as the
accommodator
forget what it's called but I don't know
if you watch Howard Stern there's always
some machine that you would listen to
someone at least listen to Howard Stern
listen to someone have sex with a robot
I'm just saying the future is now
yeah well we've done stories on robot
sex but is it is it just paranoia that
this is always gonna go poorly because
all the science fiction movies yeah they
always turn on us they kill us is that
just is there a chance that some of this
actually will be good
I think Ray Kurzweil would argue if the
robots could do all the mundane tasks of
the dishwasher and the bill pay that it
will actually free up other parts of the
human brain to do things and think about
things that we don't have time for
anymore I started doing stand-up comedy
before gps's so I literally would be
more nervous finding the place than I
was actually performing yeah so that has
freed me up the robot or whatever
technology has freed me up to be more
creative there
like if somebody could drive me the
Google car is gonna come out soon that
will free me up to play candy crush it
yeah that was actually a real world I
mean that's true like I can do I mean I
remember doing gigs and having nut drive
in upstate New York having no freaking
idea where I was gone no GPS paper that
I written the directions down yeah then
I get on stage and I'm like dripping
with sweat I'm already late yeah I mean
do you think it could free up some time
for our brains to be some other good
stuff
I mean it will it will open to candy
crush if you like close my days okay so
I did I got very far and then it was
ruining my life so I deleted it and then
three days ago I put it back on so then
using the candy crush example is this
proof that all of this is good and bad
because the robots maybe can do things
that'll be great and maybe able to do
medical procedures that will be
wonderful but then at the same time
we're all gonna get dumb because of
candy crush and is it flappy bird or
fappy bird I always but that's
somebody's yeah that would disappear I
was playing the other one I mean it
literally make tiny dumber if you're so
are they gonna make us dumber are they
gonna make us dumber with technology and
then also the robots will keep getting
smarter I don't think those games make
me dumber that's my story and I'm
sticking to it I think it makes me think
in a different way and but don't text
and drive
you're right I shouldn't drive and drive
yeah I think it's it's it's it remains
to be seen yeah the robots the jobs
robots can do are replacing like
low-paying jobs so I don't I think
they're still going to be people who
have to do for you know until 2029
they're people who have to do like the
high paying job still and I'm pretty
sure that they will not Commission the
design of a robot that allows their own
job to be replaced I
also one other thing yeah like you know
how Facebook used to be the Facebook and
then the guy from Napster came in and
talked him out of the the Facebook I
think the singularity is just gonna be
called singularity that's my prediction
singularity I mean it sounds it sounds
kind of odd thing Euler
alright people well don't forget that if
one day a robot that looks like Arnold
Schwarzenegger shows up at your door
asking for John Connor I warned you
about it